-Hey, everybody, welcome t
Corrections, week of May 17th,
you might have noticed we're
trying a different title car
this week where it will
just say "Extra."
And we'll see how
that plays for everybody.
We tried Digital Exclusive
we've tried Online Exclusive
and we're just again --
We invite your feedback
or we would invite it
if we thought that you wer
waiting for an invitation.
[ Laughter ]
Also, let's get started.
Last week I tried to land
exactly at the time,
the length that I said I would
when we started.
I said 11 minutes 28 seconds
It ended up being
11 minutes 38 seconds.
I am going to try again.
I think I'm going to try to be
a little bit looser,
try to be less precise
and give myself a window to hit.
And again, this is me
looking down my list
coming up
with how long it will be
and trying to get
in that window.
So I think based on
what I'm looking at
tonight corrections will b
13 minutes and 40 seconds,
plus or minus 10 seconds.
Okay.
Yesterday in A Closer Look
we talked about the fact
that everybody was watchin
during the January
6th insurrection.
It was one of those events
that all America was tuned into,
like the O.J. trial
or the Apollo 13 landing.
People were up in arms.
They said there was no
Apollo 13 landing
because
it never got to the moon.
But, you know, it did land
Just in the water.
I know what happened.
That's the part
that hurts my feelings.
I saw the movie "Apollo 13,"
I didn't like leave early.
I don't think the famous line is
"Houston, it all went
according to plan."
Send Ed Harris home.
And I know we could have sai
instead of landing,
we could have said the
Apollo 13 reentry or splashdown,
I'm not, I think it's very rud
to say about astronauts --
to use a term like splashdow
that sounds like
a Six Flags ride,
I'm not going to do that.
But again, if you think
if you're watching this,
you don't believe
what I'm saying right now
and you think that I thought
Apollo 13 landed on the moon
you got to stop
watching the show.
Oh, we talked about we showe
some clips from ITV
and then we, as an ITV announcer
introduced said
"Stay tuned for the shows 'Moc
the Week' and 'Taskmasters.'
And it was pointed out
that "Mock the Week" is on BBC
and "Taskmasters"
is on Channel 4.
So an ITV announcer would no
introduce those shows,
but we love those shows and we
wanted to give them a shout out.
And so that's not
that's not a mistake.
That's a we took a liberty
And for our British viewer
who were upset by that,
in America, liberty
is more than just a word.
[ Laughter ]
And if you understood that
we wouldn't have had to leave.
Also, people said you keep
calling it "Taskmasters,"
it's "Task Master."
And I understand that
in England, its "Task Master."
But here it's "Taskmasters
because sometimes people
just put an S on the end of
word like you do with "Maths."
I did a I talked about
the word psych last week
and said that I was like,
"I am, I am a puppet master.
And people said,
"That's a marionette."
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Also, someone said
I was doing Werner Herzog,
that was not
[Accent] this was not
that is not Werner --
[Normal voice] that's not.
Werner Herzog would be like,
[ As Herzog ] "Corrections
is a massive waste of time
It is foolhardy because
to be imperfect is to be human
Any effort to erase all erro
is to lose one's soul.
With that said,
I would have said splashdown
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] We had a phot
of an alligator
smoking a vape pen,
I am aware last week
we had to do a correction
about a different joke
that was a cockroach
smoking a cigarette,
and to that I'll just say
we like what we like.
So we had an alligator smoking
a vape pen
and a couple of people sai
that's a photo of a crocodile.
Yes, but here's the thing.
When we do these photo shoots,
we have found
that the crocodiles are easier
A crocodile just comes in
and does exactly
what you ask it,
we're just like "We just wan
you to smoke the vape pan"
and they're just they do it an
they're like, "Is that good?
And you go, "Yeah, you want to
just do a fun one for yourself?"
And they're like, and, and
they're just like in and out
Alligators --
And again, this is most
I'm not being specific
to all alligators,
but the ones that we deal with
in our industry
have a ton of questions.
They just show up
and they're like
"How do you want me to do that?"
And you're like "Just smoke it
the way you'd smoke a vape pen."
And they're like
they always are like,
"Okay," like it's crazy.
And they'll always say,
like, "Why is this
supposed to be funny?"
And it's like,
it wears us down.
So we have found it's easier
to just use a crocodile.
Like sometimes they'll shoot
Toronto for New York.
We do that with crocodiles
and alligators.
And Lloyd, our photographer,
is the one who's asked.
Then we stop using crocodiles.
He said, [As Lloyd]
"I nae like 'em."
[ Laughter ]
I dinnae want to work with 'em
[ Normal voice ]
He's from Scotland
and that's how he sounds.
[ Laughter ]
Um.
We talked about
some legal troubles people
been haddin --
been having excuse me
and said
that they pleaded guilty
and a lot of people
said they pled guilty.
You're wrong. You're wrong
We all want it
to be pled guilty.
That's not what it is.
It's pleaded okay.
I don't care how you do it
If you want to say plead,
that's fine.
You want to say pled.
Excuse me. That's fine.
I'm certainly not going to g
in your YouTube page
and leave a comment
because that's not who I am.
It's who you are.
But it's pleaded guilty,
right, Baze?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's pleaded guilty
I know we want it to be
pled guilty. It's not that
And if you want it to be that,
stay out of my mentions.
[ Laughter ]
Because if you're gonna
stick with it
after I'm telling you
you're wrong,
then the only thing
I have to say to you is
Amber, permission
to say "Bye, Felicia?"
-Permission granted.
-Bye, Felicia.
[ Laughter ]
It was pointed out to me
that I often say during thes
that something is
the definition of, for example
that's the definition of unfair,
when what I want to say
is that's the epitome of unfair.
Like an example
like "to call that out."
Is the epitome of pedantic
We referred to the QAnon Shama
as a QAnon Viking,
and a lot of people
pointed out he's a shaman.
And.
I apologize.
Just because someone storms th
Capitol during an insurrection
does not give me the right
to get their costume wrong
When -- my wife and I
were talking about this
because we kind
of agreed on Santa.
Like, we wouldn't pretend
once our kids figured it out
we wouldn't keep pretendin
that Santa is real, but like
when do you tell your kids
QAnon's not real?
[ Laughter ]
Because it's,
like, helpful, you know.
Like when they don't want
to do stuff,
we're like, "Alright.
But just so you know,
we'll call off we're
going to call off Q then.
And there's going to be a caba
of devil worshiping pedophiles
wandering around.
Eat your beans.
[ Laughter ]
I've talked a little bit
on this show
about Mike Shoemaker,
our producer,
who calls himself
"Mikey the Shoe,"
and one of the things he says,
anyone here can attest,
is he will say --
when you approach him
with anything --
[As Shoemaker] "I'm not afraid
of nobody!"
[ Normal voice ]
Bunch of people said to me
"That's a double negative.
I didn't say it, right.
I'd want you to understand
that when I'm telling you
what he said,
it's a direct quote.
So now you're giving me
a correction
that then I have to go tell him.
Like one of the most aggressive,
irascible people.
And I don't -- part of me wa
like, "Just leave it alone."
Right. That is not
the the remit of corrections
is not to go fix everybody
It's to fix me.
But I thought, "Alright, you
know what, I'll try it."
On behalf of the people
that took the time
to write that in, I'll go.
So I go to his office
and I say,
"Shoemaker." And again, hi
other catchphrase,
"Who's askin'?"
So I'm like,
you know my voice, bud,
you know my voice.
So I come in
and I explain to him,
When you say
"I'm not afraid of nobody,
that's a double negative.
And he goes,
"What are you talking about?
I say what basically what you're
saying is,
"I'm afraid of everybody."
And he said,
"What if that's what I meant?"
And I go, "What?"
And he said,
"Word's Mikey the Shoe
ain't as tough as he lets on."
"What if I'm putting on
a bit of a show,
with this tough exterior?"
And I said, "How would I know?
Is that true?"
He goes, "Yeah.
Been true the whole time,
I known you."
I was like,
"Why didn't you tell me?"
And he goes,
"You never asked."
So, guys, I mean. I feel
terrible, right?
And I say, "Is there anythin
I can do for you?"
He said,
"How about a hug?"
Now.
In July, I will have worked.
With Shoemaker for 20 years.
And in that time.
We've never had
any physical contact.
I remember, like, even whe
you go to shake his hand,
he's just like.
And so he asked me for a hug
you know, and, um.
I would not be
where I am today without him
And so I go over
and I give him a hug,
and the minute I do,
he just knees me in the ball
and I hit the ground and h
goes, "Oh, what happened?"
I said, "What happened?
You need me in the balls."
And he goes,
"Did I get both of them?"
I said, "Yeah,
you got both of them.
And he goes,
"That's a double negative.
[ Laughter ]
Cut the feed.